um dieses rätselhafte mini spaceshuttle
ranken sich viele verschwörungstheorien
es geht um die post ohne x-37b die seit
zwei jahren auf geheimer mission im
weltall unterwegs ist die us-luftwaffe
hält sich bedeckt und so wird fleißig
spekuliert was die mysteriöse drohne
wirklich macht wird sie etwa für geheime
spionagezwecke eingesetzt um objekte auf
der erde zu beobachten oder wurden gar
strahlen waffen im orbit positioniert
tricks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses fluggerät sieht ein wenig aus wie
eine mini version des space shuttles
aber das fluggerät x-37b der us airforce
ist unbemannt und transportiert
zumindest nach offiziellen angaben keine
astronautinnen und astronauten vor gut
zwei jahren am 17 september 2017 wurde
es mit einer falcon 9 rakete von spacex
in die erdumlaufbahn gebracht und
umkreis jetzt die erde seit zwei jahren
die aktuelle mission heißt otv 5 wobei
diese abkürzung für orbital test vehicle
steht doch die airforce hält sich extrem
bedeckt was das fluggerät eigentlich
genau macht auf der webseite der us
luftwaffe gibt es nur wenig konkrete
informationen unter anderem heißt es
technologies bringt es sind im programm
include etwa an sky dance navigation and
control for mac protection systems
avionics high temperature structures and
ziels konforme usable insulation
lightweight electro mechanical systems
advanced optischen systems advanced
materials and autonomes oppitz leid
reentry and landing grob übersetzt also
so viel wie dass es eine menge an
technologien gibt die getestet werden
unter anderem geht es um wärme
schutzsysteme hochtemperatur strukturen
und innovative antriebssysteme
offiziellen angaben der airforce zufolge
handelt es sich um ein experimentelles
testprogramm zur demonstration von
technologien für eine zuverlässige
wiederverwendbare unbemannte weltraum
plattform für die us-airforce wirklich
sehr allgemeine und vage formulierungen
die kaum etwas über die mit
schon verraten auch die kosten des x-37b
programms sind streng geheim klar ist
die lithium batterie der drohne ist
solar betrieben und in ihr steckt
sicherlich eine menge an geheimer
technik das pentagon hatte das projekt
im jahr 2004 von der nasa übernommen
jetzt liegt es in händen der
amerikanischen luftwaffe die us airforce
kann mit mindestens zwei solcher modelle
des x-37b aufwarten
die drohne wiegt rund fünf tonnen und
kann somit mit regulären raketen in den
weltraum gebracht werden viermal wurde
dazu bislang eine atlas 5 genutzt die
aktuelle mission begann mit einer falcon
die drohne ist acht meter lang dabei ist
ihre flügelspannweite mit 4,6 metern
sehr schmal die ladefläche kann man sich
vorstellen wie die eines größeren trucks
also alles kein vergleich zum space
shuttles das jahr 56 meter lang war noch
eine gemeinsamkeit gibt es auch das
mysteriöse fluggerät das derzeit im all
unterwegs ist wurde von boeing gefertigt
ist ja klar dass wenn sich die air force
mit informationen bedeckt hält das dann
hartnäckige verschwörungstheorien um
x-37b im netz kursieren manchen theorien
zufolge soll die drohne geheime spionage
betreiben und dinge auf der erde im
visier haben hatte eines der geheimen
raumschiffe vielleicht sogar eine
nutzlast mit dabei einen neuartigen
ionen antrieb der im all getestet werden
soll oder waren vielleicht sogar doch
astronauten oder astronauten mit an bord
und haben strahlen waffen im orbit
positioniert all diese wilden
spekulationen kursieren jedenfalls im
netz deutlich sicherer dagegen die
folgende info das mysteriöse fluggerät
ist mit einem orbital triebwerk mit 1,5
tonnen schub und einem enormen
treibstoffvorrat ausgestattet das
ermöglicht es ihm seine umlaufbahn um
bis zu 3,1 kilometer pro sekunde zu
verändern
seine bahn kann also mit einer geringen
vorlaufzeit so verändert werden dass es
einen bestimmten ort auf der erde zu
einer bestimmten zeit über fliegt also
spricht doch etwas für spionage noch die
umlaufbahn wurden bei den bisherigen
flügen der vorgänger nie offiziell
verkündet dennoch gelang es
interessierten amateuren bisher immer
das gerät am himmel zu entdecken und die
bahn zu berechnen doch es gibt nicht nur
viele verschwörungstheorien zu diesem
thema auch fachleute aus dem
rüstungsbereich spekulieren immer mal
wieder darüber wozu die drohne wirklich
ihnen soll handelt es sich um ein reines
aufklärungs gerät oder soll sie
satelliten transportieren reparieren
oder gar kapern
möglicherweise könnte die mysteriöse
mini version des space shuttles aber
auch in zukunft kampfflieger
unterstützen oder als hunde manta
kampfbomber dienen der vom weltall aus
zuschlägt nicht ganz abwegig wenn man
bedenkt dass das projekt beim rapid
capabilities office der us airforce
angesiedelt ist dessen aufgabe ist es
nämlich neue waffensysteme zu entwickeln
und einzuführen wann genau otv fünf
landen soll ist bisher nicht bekannt
doch einen rekord gebrochen hat die
aktuelle mission bereits sie ist länger
als andere bisherige x-37b missionen der
luftwaffe unterwegs und tv vier landet
wir nämlich bereits nachher 718
flugtagen am 7 mai 2017 in der kennedy
space center shuttle lending facility
der nasa
wo die fünf ist jetzt ja bereits seit
mehr als zwei jahren unterwegs die
nächste mission otv 6 ist bereits für
das kommende jahr 2020 geplant warum
unser raumfahrt ein zufallsprodukt ist
anklicken anschauen und raumzeit block
der zukunft abonnieren der mega kohle
kanal steht gar hans kurz vor dem
silbernen play button mit knapp 100.000
abos also hier klicken und anschauen und
abonnieren und ansonsten bis dahin
bleibt dran